we're breaking down how to talk to your
kids about money at any age
and we asked our vff's their biggest
money questions when it comes to their
kids and we have one more
angie is here and her son is a freshman
in college
angie what's your question drew thanks
so much i was wondering
the best way for eric to start building
credit right before he went to school we
got him a credit card through our bank
we're not sure how much he should be
putting on that right now he
rarely is using it because he's such in
the mode of using his debit card
and hasn't quite made that transition
over to
the credit card or even he doesn't even
know what he should be putting on there
at this point
oh i i mean those are big picture
problems so i'm going to turn that over
to farnoosh the financial expert
the most important thing when it comes
to establishing credit is to pay your
bills on time
and to not carry a balance so for
your son i would say the most important
thing is that he
hooks up that credit card to something
recurring some
easy stuff that he's paying for
regularly that he can absolutely pay off
every single month in full automatically
so he's never late
and that will while he's sleeping help
him establish credit
and elisa what is good rhetoric and
advice
to talk about sort of you know the
benefits of being on time with payments
and lacking drama in your life basically
out of the gate from early on allow your
kids
teenagers and young adults to fail in
these small ways financially so that
they learn from those mistakes and you
don't save them
early in the and then it's a disservice
later when
they really are in big trouble i like
that
i think we're so afraid to let our kids
fail
and we stop them from learning vital
coping mechanisms
um psychologically and then financially
i hope that helped
um yes thank you so much oh of course
i'm so excited to just
you know start getting organized about
this so many other things have been
my priority with my kids and i realized
i had sort of left this one in the
rearview mirror and i was ready to pick
it up so
how do parents tackle the fear and how
do kids get out of
abstract thinking when it comes to money
i know for myself
it was really coming to terms with my
relationship with money and why
i had the relationship that i had so
understanding
my parents understanding the
circumstances under which i was raised
and going
okay that was that's my story but that
doesn't have to be my kid's
story right that's my narrative i don't
i can just i can choose what i want to
pass on from that narrative
to my kids and then for kids i think
it's you know exercising a lot of the
tips that we share today which is
including them in the experiences that
you're having around
spending and saving the first thing is
always
be the kind of parent your kids can come
to about uncomfortable subjects
about anything and give them the message
both in your body language and in your
openness
that they can come to you with any of
these tricky topics
and then answer them when you feel
comfortable and if you don't feel
comfortable
take a beat say i really love that you
asked that question
i want to give you a thoughtful answer
so i'm going to get back to you
that's all i love this
okay thank you guys so much this is an
excellent way
for myself to begin on this journey and
just get started with kids our age thank
you so much thank you dr
eliza and thank you far news
you